[Música]
todo lo que hago tiene que ver con
intentar comprender el futuro y para eso
una de las mejores herramientas que
utilizo es la curiosidad ir por el
camino levantando piedritas intentando
encontrar cosas nuevas debajo de cada
una de ellas sin embargo para generar
progreso únicamente la curiosidad nos
sirve es necesario poner a prueba los
prejuicios que todos cargamos y que de
alguna manera se disparan cada vez que
debajo de cada una de esas piedras
encontramos algo que no se corresponde
con la visión o que lo que nosotros
opinamos de como el mundo debe ser decía
wolf vostell qué es lo que no conocéis
lo que os cambiará la vida y justo de
eso es de lo que trata esta sesión
uno de los temas que más me interesan y
más siendo padre de una niña de seis
años es el tema de la diversidad en
general pero del feminismo en particular
es bastante obvio que mi experiencia al
respecto de lo que significa ser mujer
es bastante superficial y por tanto mi
opinión sobre el feminismo era una que
estaba únicamente basada en agregar
capas y capas de información a favor y
en contra de lo que todos nos
encontramos cada día en nuestro contexto
perdón y no fue hasta hace unos meses en
que tuve por fin una epifanía que me
permitió comprender como yo podía
argumentar algo al respecto de este tema
y fue cuando en un evento en la ciudad
de mexico me encontré con la frase que
este chico lleva en su sudadera de let
voices beat femenino
ahora les cuento porque es una epifanía
pero antes voy a hacer un display porque
creo que este es un tema del que
deberíamos hablar más y el problema es
que en muchas ocasiones las
conversaciones se reducen a intentar
tener la razón o arrinconar el
adversario para descalificarlo o
etiquetarlo de una u otra manera en vez
de navegar en todos esos grises en los
que probablemente pudiéramos encontrar
lugares de acuerdo y de construcción de
nuevas ideas eso es justo lo que
pretendo con esta charla no pretendo que
todos estén de acuerdo con todo lo que
voy a decir es más pueden rechazar el
99,9 por ciento de lo que voy a decir
pero si hay un punto 1 por ciento que
les resuena en positivo ya tenemos algo
en común a partir de lo cual construir
algo nuevo que no existía antes estoy
consciente igualmente y este es el
display nerd de que hay personas a las
que probablemente no les va a gustar
nada de lo que voy a decir aquí es más
es probable que lo manifiesten de manera
agria con epítetos de todo tipo como
todos estos que pueden ver en la
pantalla y ningún nueva pilla de
sorpresa porque probablemente ya los he
escuchado o
y digo no me ofenden porque entiendo
perfectamente del lugar del que vienen
todos estos comentarios vienen de un
lugar que se denomina el man box hay
muchas nomenclaturas pero este es el que
vamos a usar específicamente en los
próximos 18 minutos que es el lugar
abstracto que contiene todas las
características que definen el
estereotipo de género masculino con el
que convivimos los hombres desde que
nacemos mientras crecemos y hasta que
llegamos a la edad adulta hace un año y
medio más o menos
unilever encargó la
realización de este estudio en el cual
se le preguntaba a miles de varones de
reino unido eeuu y méxico al respecto de
cuáles eran las características que
ellos pensaban que tenían que tener para
ser considerados hombres de verdad
nótense las comillas el resultado arrojó
una serie de respuestas que se podían
agrupar en siete características que
pueden ver aquí no con esto estoy
diciendo que los hombres somos así ni
mucho menos sino que preguntados miles
de varones al respecto de lo que ellos
creen que han de tener para ser
considerados hombres de verdad los
resultados se pueden categorizar en
siete características los hombres de
verdad no piden ayuda no lloran los
hombres de verdad tienen cuadritos en el
abdomen los hombres de verdad tienen que
estar tienen que ser otros sexuales para
empezar tienen que estar dispuestos a
tener sexo en cualquier momento y no
sexo normal el sexo de película
pornográfica porque esta es una
educación sexual que los hombres hemos
recibido desde la hoja de internet un
hombre de verdad tiene y debe saber con
quién y dónde está su pareja en cada
momento etcétera etcétera etcétera así
pensando en que estas características
son las que están dentro de la caja que
como buena caja es un lugar cerrado uno
pudiera pensar que hay un montón de
características igualmente interesantes
que se quedan fuera de ella si quedan
fuera de ella porque son características
que aparentemente son percibidas como
femenina quedan fuera el compartir queda
fuera el amor por los detalles queda
fuera la empatía queda fuera el llorar y
todo este tipo de cosas que a lo mejor
les puede parecer que son puras
anécdotas pero piensen que las
características que están viviendo
dentro de esta caja no solo definen cómo
se manifiesta individualmente cada
individuo sino que también determinan la
visión y el enfoque mediante el cual se
relacionan con el mundo que les rodea
así que piensen en la diferencia entre
vivir dentro o fuera para algo como el
matrimonio un lugar de construcción
conjunta con tu pareja o bien un lugar
en el que tu pareja es tu prisionera o
en el sexo como el lugar donde se
encarna la culminación del amor de dos
personas o en el sexo simplemente como
una labor de caza y captura como se
hacía en la antigüedad con los animales
y así sucesivamente
yo lo sé porque imagino que como muchos
varones aquí en la sala yo he vivido
dentro de esa caja durante muchísimos
años y mirando un poco hacia atrás me da
cierta cierta resignación cierta
nostalgia cierta cierto arrepentimiento
al respecto de cómo muchas de mis
relaciones o experiencias se han
deteriorado por culpa de la visión
limitada con la que accedía a todas
ellas así que sabiendo esto pueden hacer
dos cosas se pueden usar la analogía de
las pastillas y pueden tomarse el azul
para decir bueno pero el pedo está así
así que no hay nada que yo pueda hacer y
volvamos a la normalidad que había antes
de venir a esta sala o bien pueden
intentar tomar la roja para ver qué hay
más allá de esa realidad que nos han
contado que hay porque es obvio que algo
está pasando así que cuando vi esta
frase para meter todo el sentido del
mundo porque para mí el hecho de que un
nombre sea más femenino no tiene nada
que ver con que cambie su orientación
sexual o con que vista de tal o cual
color como si además eso lo volviera
menos hombre sino que tiene que ver con
el hecho de que ese hombre adopta una
serie de características que de alguna
manera lo vuelven más
perceptivo más sensible a sí mismo hacia
el exterior y para con los demás esto se
puede manifestar de muchos ejemplos pero
yo encontré este tan divertido unos
obreros en reino unido a los que les
prohibieron llevar shorts en un día en
que hacía tanto calor no tanto como en
sonora
les obligaron a llevar su traje y ellos
descubrieron el reglamento que nada les
impedía llevar falda con lo cual
decidieron ir a trabajar en falda y
alguien puede decir ah pues de eso se
trata entonces de llevar falda no de lo
que se trata es de que cuando te libras
de lo que se supone que las cosas
deberían ser entre el juego el
pensamiento lateral que te permite
resolver problemas de una manera que no
habías considerado previamente por el
hecho de que eres libre del corsé que
tenías viviendo des dentro de esa caja
así que para mí es un gran hallazgo es
que el feminismo es una de las mejores
cosas que nunca le pudieron haber pasado
al género masculino pero no para opinar
sobre ello porque como hombres creo que
no tenemos nada que opinar al respecto
sino que viendo como el feminismo ha
ayudado a las mujeres a desarrollarse a
lo largo de la historia quizá nosotros
debiéramos encontrar una equivalencia
una analogía un movimiento equivalente
que nos permitiera redefinir lo que
significa ser hombre hoy lejos de
probablemente el estereotipo de género
troglodita en el que muchas personas de
género masculino todavía viven hoy así
que decidí agrupar los cinco motivos por
los que creo que adoptar o entender o
intentar comprender mejor
feminismo porque no es fácil puede
ayudarles a progresar en la vida la
primera de ellas es probablemente la que
más ampollas y susceptibilidades levanta
el tema de la justicia sobre todo porque
parte de premisas que no se entienden
del todo bien como por ejemplo decir que
feminismo es la contraposición cultural
el machismo cuando no lo es en absoluto
el machismo es un movimiento de opresión
y el feminismo lo que busca es la
equidad la igualdad de oportunidades
esta imagen que mi amiga halle me envió
desde una escuela en beirut lo resume
muy bien 2 y 7 y 4 y 5 son lo mismo pero
no son iguales y si entienden esta
analogía tan fácil ya estarán preparados
para dejar de decir cosas como que si
las mujeres quieren igualdad que carguen
ellas los garrafones o en un tenor más
grave reprimir esas ganas de decir ni
uno menos cada vez que hay una mujer que
muere y hay compañeras que deciden
escribir ni una menos en una red social
claro danielle tú no lo entiendes
también están muriendo hombres de hecho
mueren muchos más hombres que las
mujeres y no nos quejamos el 80% de los
hombres son hombres daniel 70% de los
suicidios son de hombres el 97% de los
muertos en la guerra son hombres
danielle los hombres viven 5 años menos
que las mujeres y no nos quejamos aunque
tenemos problemas es como si tienes
todos esos problemas pero no es culpa
del feminismo ni de las mujeres el
feminismo no mata el machismo sí y la
estructura en la cual se afianza y se
ejecuta el machismo que es el
patriarcado también nos perjudica a los
hombres el problema es que como hombres
como sólo hablamos de tetas fútbol y
política entonces nunca nos da por decir
que tenemos problemas en voz alta hasta
que una mujer o un homosexual reclama
algo tan simple como el hecho de que no
le pongan una madriza por el hecho de
ser mujer web o sexual así que esto que
pareciera tan obvio es algo complicado y
de lo vas descubriendo en lugares
insospechados por ejemplo en este texto
de este autor al que yo seguía por otros
motivos porque es un personaje muy
reconocido en el mundo
y que un día escribía que las demandas
de la masculinidad casi habían acabado
con él y con su matrimonio por algo tan
simple como por el hecho de que a los
hombres la única emoción que se nos
permite mostrar en público es el enojo y
todas las demás las guardamos y las
embotellamos y sólo las manifestamos
como explosión con consecuencias
bastante desafortunadas las más de las
veces así que tengo la impresión de que
estamos asistiendo y viviendo en tiempo
real a un momento histórico tan
comparable como el movimiento por
ejemplo por los derechos civiles en eeuu
hay una guerra de las mujeres no contra
el hombre sino contra el patriarcado y
siendo una guerra creo que es
conveniente posicionarse uno de los
bandos yo me gustaría pensar que
deberíamos saber escoger en qué bando de
la historia queremos estar si no los
convencí con esto creo que también
podrían adoptar o hablar más de
feminismo si quieren ser más creativos
sobre todo porque eso nos lleva a hablar
de una palabra hoy muy interesante en un
país con tanta desigualdad social como
en méxico la palabra privilegio que
siempre tienen otros pero si lo piensan
todos somos privilegiados para alguien
más y el privilegio es una palabra que
cuando tú se la aplicas a alguien y le
dices a alguien eres privilegiado les
habrá pasado no se ofenden yo nosotros
yo no soy privilegiado todo lo que tengo
me lo he ganado con el sudor de
diferente he trabajado muchísimo de sol
a sol etcétera y es como si nadie está
poniendo eso en duda porque el
privilegio no habla de tu capacidad del
privilegio habla de que comenzaste con
ventaja con respecto a otros que no
tenían ese privilegio de esto sí les
puedo hablar de primera mano porque soy
muy privilegiado soy hombre soy blanco
soy heterosexual y adicionalmente yo no
lo busque pero resulta que por el hecho
de ser europeo en américa latina américa
latina' me obsequia con un privilegio
que otras personas que no se ven como yo
no tienen así que uno pudiera pensar
está padrísimo tener el privilegio y sí
pero no por lo que ustedes creen porque
si yo quisiera ser un ser más
sofisticado
más informado más creativo el hecho de
verme cómo me veo y juntarme con gente
que se ve cómo me veo yo no me sirve
para mucho lo único que voy a crear es
más de lo que ya hay si quiero crear
algo distinto entonces debería juntarme
con gente distinta con gente que tiene
una experiencia del mundo distinta a la
mía
posiblemente además menos privilegiada
así que uno pensaría que si yo mañana
abrir una nueva compañía contrataría a
todo el mundo que se viera distinto a
como yo me veo simplemente por el hecho
de que todos aquellos que no son parte
del status quo luchan diariamente contra
él y tienen ideas más frescas y
poderosas para cambiarlo el privilegio
no es una palabra negativa lo negativo
es la forma en la que muchas personas lo
usan para intentar reducir al mundo y
que el mundo sea de aquellos que se ven
de una determinada manera pero si lo
piensan el privilegio es una palabra o
una herramienta poderosísima para
extender el mundo y hacerlo más grande
en tamaño y en oportunidades para tanta
gente que hoy todavía no las tiene si no
les convence con la creatividad o con la
justicia les traigo una tercera vivir
mejor laboralmente ya qué me refiero con
esto me refiero a que yo por ejemplo
adoro mi trabajo pero adoro mucho más a
mi hija pero si lo piensan es terrible
el hecho de que muchas personas tenga
escoger entre su vida personal o laboral
para poder mantener a su familia al
final de mes lo cual hace pensar en que
así como las mujeres han ido encontrando
cada vez mejores ejemplos de cómo
desarrollarse y de cómo desempeñarse
tanto en el ámbito personal como en el
laboral
los hombres seguimos teniendo unos role
models que al final en la última
encarnación siguen valorando las mismas
tres cosas mujeres dinero carro poder
posesiones como lo quieran llamar no nos
faltan role models nuevos que vivan
fuera de esa caja porque con los valores
que les acabo de decir el epítome de eso
la máxima expresión de esos valores es
donald trump
el horror yo la verdad no quiero tener
eso como role model a seguir pero si se
lo plantean y piensan entonces como hay
que criar a un hijo varón hoy y piensan
en ejemplos a partir de los cuales ese
hijo varón puede encontrar una escala de
valores basada en la expresión de su
identidad y no el número de ceros de su
cuenta bancaria nos faltan billy elliot
lo cual es un problema en el futuro
porque piensen que si un hombre hoy
decide decir que le han acosado lo
primero que va a suceder es que se van a
reír de él porque no es suficientemente
hombre o que si un hombre decide tomarse
unos meses de baja por paternidad para
atender a su hijo probablemente no se la
van a conceder porque es algo
prácticamente inexistente en las leyes y
si esto es algo que es es un terreno
doloroso y complicado de navegar para
una mujer es un terreno que directamente
para un hombre no existe así que uno
pudiera pensar que mucho de lo que las
mujeres reclaman laboralmente también
nos sería de utilidad a nosotros
más aún porque en una época en la que
parece que nos dirigimos a que todo
trabajo que no tenga que ver con la
creatividad va a ser reemplazado por una
máquina la única esperanza que podemos
tener de materia de nuestro trabajo es
que sea creativo y si no tenemos una
vida interesante nuestro trabajo no será
creativo no podrás tener un trabajo
interesante si tu vida no lo es y todos
los convenzo les tengo otra que a lo
mejor les gusta más escoger el feminismo
para ganar más dinero y no me refiero
con esto a esa especie de capitalismo
disfrazado de feminismo que hace que
aparezcan playeras en sara con la
leyenda feminista que propiamente
produjo una mujer a un precio irrisorio
en algún lugar del mundo sino que me
refiero al hecho de que hay segmentos de
población que están patentemente
desatendidos
estas imágenes evocan muchas cosas desde
lo inspiracional pueden ver a esta niña
afroamericana haciendo un retrato de
michelle obama oa esta otra niña que es
una de las cientos de miles de niñas que
decidió en 2017 disfrazarse de wonder
woman por halloween
y esto no sólo es interesante desde el
punto de vista aspiracional sino desde
el punto de vista del mercado que mueven
no sé si leyeron alguna vez esta noticia
pero después del estreno de black
panther en eeuu muchos de los directores
o dueños de cadenas de cines escribieron
a los estudios pidiendo que hubiera más
diversidad de protagonistas en esas
móvil porque fíjense qué estupidez que
si ves a alguien haciendo cosas
increíbles en una pantalla y esa persona
se ve como tú tú estás dispuesto a pagar
un boleto para ir a ver no agreguen a
ese dato el hecho de que en 2017 el 83
por ciento del consumo de eeuu lo
generaron las mujeres es decir
las mujeres compran cosas y las mujeres
deciden cosas es muy ingenuo pensar que
el domicilio de una familia o el coche
de una familia es una decisión del varón
de la familia seamos honestos
y aún así si lo contraponen con la
realidad publicitaria en la cual
trabajan muchos hombres blancos como yo
haciendo propaganda para otros hombres
blancos como yo podremos ver y pueden
hacer el ejercicio de ver cuántos
comerciales de coches recuerdan dónde
conduce una mujer el auto y luego salgan
a la calle vean cuántas mujeres manejan
autos en ciudad obregón sonora y van a
ver que hay una disparidad patente eso
no sólo se refleja en el hecho de que
haya publicidad sesgada y malísima allá
afuera que no le habla a las mujeres
sino que supone además que hay una serie
de productos que están rotos y no me
refiero a rotos porque estén mal hechos
sino que están rotos porque están
creados desde la perspectiva de hombres
blancos como yo que no tenemos ni la
visión ni la sensibilidad ni la
experiencia de lo que significa ser
mujer a principios de este año este
artículo new york times' analizaba el
funcionamiento de algunos de los
algoritmos de reconocimiento facial de
algunas de las compañías más famosas del
mundo elija en la que quiera
y el resultado que arrojaba era que si
eres un hombre blanco el algoritmo te
reconoce un 99 por ciento de las veces
si eres una mujer blanca un 93 si eres
un hombre de tez morena o de raza negra
88 pero si eres una mujer con la piel
oscura 65% de cada 100 veces hay 65 en
las que puede acertar de 35 de
probabilidad en las que no piensen en
las consecuencias catastróficas que
tiene eso en un lugar donde todos nos
vemos y convivimos con pieles de todos
los colores para el futuro así que uno
pudiera pensar que si consideran esos
segmentos de mercado que ahora no se
consideran y hacen bien todos estos
productos que hoy están rotos para que
sean igualitarios y en igualdad de
oportunidades para todos sus usuarios
uno pudiera pensar que hay mucho dinero
esperando les si no los convencí con la
justicia con la creatividad con vivir la
mejor laboralmente con dinero verdad no
sé qué esperan de la vida pero si no los
convencí con ninguna de esas les tengo
una última y es que creo que el
feminismo es inédita
y es inevitable porque está en la mesa
servido para que todos hablen de él a
favor y en contra y cuando las marcas
empiezan a apropiarse de movimientos y
los visten de imaginería tan poderosa y
badass como esta que saco nike y este
año uno pudiera pensar que es un lugar
del que ya no se puede volver porque más
allá de lo que obtienen de sí es una
campaña y si es para vender tenis y bla
bla bla lo que está margen de boca es
una imagen súper contemporánea de un
segmento de la población que está hasta
la madre y lo que se ve aquí es un grito
de furia y de rabia no queriendo volver
a pasar en silencio por todo lo que han
tenido que pasar durante los últimos
siglos esto no es nada nuevo
tocqueville que era un historiador y
diplomático francés que estudió la
democracia en américa en los albores y
también la revolución francesa decía que
las revoluciones no se producen porque
haya un oprimido que se levanta contra
el opresor sino que se producen cuando
hay un segmento de población que tiene
una expectativa que no se ve satisfecha
en aquel caso en el siglo 18 la
burguesía francesa hoy digo yo las
mujeres porque cuando alguien encuentra
su voz es imposible que se calle
así que si son o conocen a alguien que
cada vez que escucha o ve la palabra
feminismo se ataca de los nervios
estar harto de este asunto y piensa que
las mujeres están sublevadas y que son
muy ruidosas y que se quejan por nada
les tengo una mala noticia esto no se va
a detener va a ser cada vez más ruidoso
y más rápido y si piensan que las
mujeres están sublevadas hoy tendrían
que ver cómo es la siguiente generación
tengo una hija de 6 años puedo afirmarlo
en primera persona y sobre todo porque
si siguen pensando que el rol de la
mujer no tiene que ver con lo que han
ido construyendo en las últimas décadas
les voy a decir algo terrible pero van a
estar buscando a una mujer que ya no
existe así que tienen dos opciones step
the fuck
up o step de fuck out ustedes eligen
cuál quieren tienen cinco motivos para
escoger el feminismo pero como les dije
al inicio yo me dedico a estudiar el
futuro y algo muy relevante para el
futuro es el hecho de cómo nos vamos a
relacionar entre nosotros y para con el
entorno que nos rodea dentro de unos
años porque para eso incluso
probablemente hay personas personas aquí
perdón que se estén dedicando a ello
se escucha hoy mucho la palabra
algoritmo no y la inteligencia
artificial automatización etcétera
etcétera esto sugiere preguntas
interesantes porque si las máquinas
están aprendiendo quién diablos y que
les están enseñando sobre todo en una
época en la que hemos decidido asignarle
a los algoritmos y a la inteligencia
artificial propiedades casi
sobrenaturales no hablaba antes el
manuel de hal 9000
yo también es como un slide repetido
pero piensen en como la inteligencia
artificial explora nuestras
inseguridades matemáticas no de repente
es como debe haber visto esto en la
escuela pero no presté suficiente
atención a nuestras inseguridades
laborales no es mi trabajo lo
suficientemente interesante para que no
me lo quite una máquina estoy a salvo o
no y qué voy a hacer si me lo quita
existenciales incluso porque todos hemos
visto un montón de películas donde al
9000 o skynet toman decisiones al
respecto de cómo la raza humana va a
vivir en los próximos años no y aquí no
está will smith perdón por mi referencia
revela mi edad
no sé para los jóvenes quién será así
zac efron o quien sea
no lo tenemos aquí para salvarnos pero
toda esta magia que le asignamos a los
algoritmos nos hace olvidar y perder de
vista el punto de que los algoritmos son
construidos y programas entrenados por
personas como nosotros y los prejuicios
que esas personas tienen se transmiten a
esos algoritmos a lo mejor no en la
programación o en la construcción pero
sí en cómo se entrenan como pudieron ver
en el ejemplo anterior parece absurdo
pensar que un algoritmo pueda ser
racista pero puede suceder si las
personas que lo entrenan no están
atentos a ello
de hecho los algoritmos nos otra cosa
más que la opinión de alguien escrita en
código así que celebro mucho que estén
hoy aquí intentando reunir y conectar
nuevas ideas que les permitan como
piezas de lego construir el nuevo mundo
de los próximos años pero antes de
hacerlo creo que tienen que detenerse 10
segundos y mirar alrededor y estar
conscientes de que cualquier cosa que
hagan tiene efectos no sólo sobre las
personas que son y se ven como ustedes
sino también sobre las que no eso es un
poder pero también una responsabilidad
los animo a que levanten las piedras a
que sean curiosos a que abracen la
diversidad de la diferencia que no sean
miedosos y sean valientes para adaptar
nuevas cualidades y sobre todo que
siempre tengan la oportunidad en la
tesitura de una pastilla azul o una
pastilla roja escojan siempre la roja
hay muchas pastillas rojas pero una que
les puede servir mucho y por la que
pueden empezar es la del feminismo
gracias
[Aplausos]